this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode we're back for the second
part of jonathan's look at the weapons
of ready or not something i've gone on
about previously from from the good old
days of rainbow six and swap and games
like that is realistic ammunition
management which john browning be
praised uh
we have in this game if you want to see
more of jonathan's take on ready or not
make sure to subscribe and check our
previous episode on the game's firearms
and for something a little bit different
we have david rawlings a swordmaster of
over 25 years breaking down some of the
weapons of eldon ring in my many years
of fighting the kraken
there's nothing i can find wrong with
this right let's get back to the guns of
ready or not
okay i just want to say that i very much
enjoy the reloading the brass check or
press check animations that are included
kind of pointlessly but i mean that in a
good way so you know in a game more more
so even in real life you know absolutely
for sure when you're when your gun is
loaded but it still affords you the
ability to check for cool points and
it's a nod toward the the real world
where double checking that you
definitely have chambered around is
something that is done the reload of
this shotgun so this is this is a less
lethal shotgun based on a remington 870
it has the coloured furniture so that
ideally you don't load the wrong
ammunition in it and cause a serious
incident there have been shotguns
historically where they only chamber
safe ammunition from what i can tell
it's more reliant upon good training and
color coding and things like that now
but um if anyone has more experience on
that please do make a comment below the
loading of the cartridges is such a
simple thing we've seen it done
since the beginning of first person
shooters they tend to fly in there at
super speed and it's
not an issue at all but if you've ever
loaded a tube
fed firearm you know it does require a
bit of effort it requires a bit of
practice to do it smoothly and quickly
and i get a hint of that here so i get a
bit of the weight and effort required to
insert a cartridge it's very hard to do
um but i think they've done a good job
there and then with the classic pump
action sound as well this one's a less
lethal one but they seem to have nailed
the pump action quite nicely
restrained suspect is visible
drop your way
drop it down
drop it now okay i won't do anything
else
right so some a good demonstration there
of the theory of less than lethal
weapons in the context of beanbag
shotguns or um perhaps baton rounds so
you are shooting someone with a 12 gauge
pump action shotgun but the ammunition
is the thing is the thing is different
of course and it's essentially a it's a
sort of remote truncheon really it's
about causing pain discomfort confusion
and making people rethink their life
choices when they are otherwise
potentially going to shoot at you and we
saw it actually work quite well there
i'm sure that's not always the case the
guy the character took
a couple of rounds and decided yeah
maybe i'll put my gun down and surrender
and that is of course the the theory of
a weapon like this of course the
downside of leslie for weapons is that
they are less reliable when it comes to
stopping
a threat so you they have to typically
be used in conjunction with lethal
weapons in case things go badly for the
less lethal option chat there took a
bean bag round i think it's meant to be
in in the side of the head not a good
idea you don't want to be shooting
people in the head with anything if you
could possibly avoid it because of
course the risk of head injury is even
with a less lethal weapon is much
increased and although it's interesting
that that did appear to actually knock
him out momentarily um incidentally i
don't know if the the white kind of
powder effect that shows you your point
of impact with this as i have no no
experience with beanbag shotguns i don't
know if that's realistic or not if
anyone knows
let me know down below
okay the the beretta this is not by any
means out of place in this in this
universe they are still in use beretta's
becoming less common perhaps in swat
teams anyway but but they're still out
there and this is a recent
model this is the 92x
it's got the frame mounted safety that
normally would make you think this is a
taurus but not so this is actually this
is actually a beretta a couple of other
modern features as well or more modern
but what draws my eye is the are the
fake manufacturers markings on the side
so we've got what looks a lot like a
beretta logo but i'm sure it's different
and then the name padania
now i i did actually have to look this
up padania is a separatist movement in
northern italy and beretta is from
northern italy and we we have some 16th
century firearms from that same region
so there's a very strong and long
tradition of firearms manufacture in
that area but um yeah rather than
putting
brescia on the side they've put fodania
which is interesting and hopefully
doesn't cause some sort of political
backlash
we've got a lot of detail on here as
soon as is the case for all of these
good magazine modeling i i've in the
couple of years we've been doing this
series i've
finally home sense for when people
bother to model magazines correctly
we've come a long way from just a
collection of polygons with nothing in
the top to
fake round in the top but it's not
positioned realistically to something
that actually looks like what you would
insert into the grip or in this case
into the grip of the pistol double stack
rounds in there cut out for the mag
catch some scratches and texturing on
there to make it look like it might
actually be a real thing for years
magazines have been neglected so it's
nice to see a good effort there
something i'm seeing on all the guns so
far is
a really nice
heat haze effect around the muzzle it's
really nice but it's not something i've
ever been aware of shooting a gun i
think you'd have to get the gun
pretty hot to be to be and i
know this is the case it can happen but
you would have to fire a lot of rounds
in the right sort of atmospheric
conditions to be able to see the heat
haze around the barrel it's the same
same effect of course as driving on a
hot road you see the heat haze above the
top of the hot tarmac absolutely can
happen in this situation after after the
first few shots i'd probably not with
certainly not with a pistol
not getting hot enough quick enough to
create that effect so interesting to see
not so i think it perhaps needs to be
scaled back a bit
yeah something i've gone on about
previously from from the good old days
of rainbow six and swat and games like
that ghost recon is realistic ammunition
management which john browning be
praised uh
we have in this game so if you fire a
couple of rounds take your magazine out
put it imaginarily somewhere on your kit
when you then come back to you you have
the you have the rounds that you have
and if you put that around that magazine
back in the weapon you have that many
rounds still in the magazine they're not
automatically leveled out and topped up
i really like it when games do realistic
ammunition management and in this
situation it adds a real
hell of a lot to the gameplay as well if
you can just do the cod reflex reload
after two rounds every time admittedly
that gets you killed if you know you can
do that you can always prepare for a
situation if you have to remember that
you've got less than half a mag for your
pistol and you're on your last couple of
shots in your rifle it makes you think
it ratchets up the tension and makes the
game so much more fun big fan of it so
we have got some variety and reloads as
well got a nice retention reload on the
beretta there where the partially
expanded magazine is withdrawn a fresh
one is already in the hand you insert
the other one and then you pocket or
pouch the magazine you've taken off so
it's got all sort of tactical bells and
whistles that we want to see in terms of
modern thinking in how you should move
and shoot through an environment like
this
right g36 i've grabbed one of our
many g36s so this is this is a g36c as
depicted in ready or not
pretty much with a couple of differences
these are modular firearms so there are
differences so the trigger group this
one's semi-automatic only um the concern
there being that even well-trained
firearms officers might accidentally
flick to automatic and
accidentally hit people that they
shouldn't be hitting it's deemed that
all they need is
semi-automatic self-loading only so
that's that's what this has in the game
of course i think people would be
disappointed if it was semi-only being
you based on us
special weapons and tactics teams by
default they tend to have select fire
available to them it's also accessorized
like the one in the game now the the
glaring difference here is this still
has its
traditional g36 picatinny rail carry
handle slash
optical sight rail the version in the
game is a configuration i have seen but
that we haven't got where it just has a
front sight block and effectively a rear
sight block with picatinny on and the
whole top of the weapon is left open
that's a bit of a weird configuration in
my view just it seems a bit a bit
bizarre it doesn't reduce the footprint
of the weapon as it were all it does is
open open up the cocking handle to
potentially getting struck by something
unlikely but nonetheless because this is
the cocking handle by the way or
charging handle lock it into place there
accessible from both sides a good
feature of the g36 and it also means
that you don't have the real estate
across the top of the weapon for
placement of the optics so you would
have to be happy with something like a
micro red dot quite up close
back here
they may not be an issue there may be
guys out there running those
those versions but i'm not really clear
on why you'd bother and the vast
majority that you see in actual use do
still have
that
carry handle in place
now another cool feature here that isn't
too often depicted although some of some
of the more famous depictions are in
things like call of duty and that is
night vision with in with an infrared
illuminator so this this g36 has been
equipped with laser light module or i
think in this case just a laser that's
invisible to the to the naked eye but
when you put your night vision device on
it's plain as day to you and your team
members who are using night vision but
the enemy or in this case suspects
haven't got a clue that they're being
literally lit up so you can really quite
precisely aim at close quarters with
effectively a laser sight only it's
infrared so it can't be seen by anyone
who isn't wearing night vision
right well i didn't mention it with the
mp5 which is an egregious oversight but
uh with the mp5 we don't get the
infamous hk slap the game is sort of
differentiating itself by
not doing that and it's just which is
completely fine you lose major cool
points of course but um simply
knocking the uh cocking handle out of
the slot and letting it fly forward is
completely legitimate and that's how
this game handles the mp5 now where a
lot of games perhaps not get it wrong
but depicted in the wrong order i
suppose is with the ump which is uh what
i'm watching at the moment where you can
manually lock the bolt open like an mp5
and you can slap it out of the slot if
you wish but the way you're supposed to
reload it is with the ar15 style ping
pong paddle as they sometimes call it on
the left side of the gun and ready or
not has you use that it doesn't have you
manually lock it open change the mags
and slap the handle down which you can
do but this gun is set up to meet the
market demand
for ar-15 style ergonomics otherwise
it's a ump the ump rarely appears in its
nine millimeter form because what's the
point uh you may as well have the 45 to
give you a sort of stopping power
difference and of course that gives you
proportionately more recoil than
something like an mp5 which is true it
does in real life i often have a problem
with video game guns that are polymer
bodied not looking like plastic this
definitely does look like plastic it's
maybe a bit too shiny it looks like it's
plastic that's been handled a lot and
polymer guns do get a lot of handling in
certain areas and certain types of
polymer do turn shiny not so much your
glass reinforced nylon type glock style
polymer that the ump is made out of they
tend to just get scuffed and worn
looking with scratches and dings and
chewed up bits they don't tend to go
shiny like this but this is extremely
nitpicky
suspect
right the scar not too much of a
surprise necessarily to see this
although i'm not sure that
police would necessarily have the mark
16 mod 0 version so for those who don't
know the mark 16 mod 0 is the us navy
designation for the select fire fn scar
light or l and that's what's modeled
here in its short-barreled condition we
have got one i didn't grab it today i
think a u.s police department's more
likely correct if i'm wrong to have the
commercial equivalent of that so the
difference would really only be in the
markings there because when i say
commercial i don't mean civilian
semi-auto only i mean select fire fn
scar but it's not the us military
adopted version the way this is modeled
and the way the player character holds
it is a good illustration of why some
people are not fans of reciprocating
cocking handles so the charging handle
cocking handle on the left side flying
back and forth for quite a rate of speed
if you happen to pop your thumb up in
front of that at the very least you're
going to stop the weapon from cycling
and it might also smart as well so for
that reason fn or fnusa anyway have
introduced a
non-reciprocating charging handle
version although i don't know if that's
offered to military and law enforcement
plenty of other users don't seem to have
a problem with it and this chap is
keeping his knuckles well out of the way
right shotguns um benelli m4 modern
benchmark for tactical shotgun we
haven't got one all donations gratefully
accepted
yeah it makes perfect sense it would be
in this game it's semi-automatic
12-gauge gives you flexibility very
powerful up close and as the game
correctly depicts
can reach out to well maybe 50 yards
something like that with buckshot or a
slug and still
have a considerable effect this is not
your doom 2 super shotgun the reload is
a very very modern competition inspired
over the shoulder flip the gun over and
load in that fashion not i don't i don't
think they're doing any sort of quad
loads or anything john wick's style but
um that's the first time i've seen that
style of reload in a video game
please get down
if you'd like to check out the royal
armouries youtube channel alongside
this one please do we also have various
of our own social media outlets and
three rather nice museums that you can
come and visit and as ever if you'd be
kind enough to donate to us we don't
require it by any means but um there is
a link in the description thanks again
guys
[Music]
[Music]
you